the modern united states is the most
powerful country in human history
with over 800 military bases and 37
of global military spending the us has
become the leader of a vast
interconnected global system that has
helped
usher in an era of unprecedented
prosperity and low levels of conflict
to understand america's position in the
world and why it's so pivotal for world
politics as we know it you have to go
back to the country's founding
back to when america wasn't a global
power in any sense of the word
during the first 70 years of its
existence the united states expanded in
both territory and influence in north
america
eventually reaching the pacific ocean in
a wave of expansionism that resulted in
the wholesale slaughter
of the indigenous people who populated
the continent but early americans were
deeply divided as to whether the country
should expand beyond the pacific and
atlantic oceans
this became a major debate after the
civil war when some leaders like
post-war secretary of state seward
argued that america should push to
become a global power
seward succeeded in pushing a plan to
purchase alaska from russia
but his attempts to buy greenland and
iceland as well as annexed territory in
the caribbean
were all blocked by congress that's
because some americans including many on
capitol hill
had a strong anti-imperialist bent these
people worried about america getting
more involved in global politics
as well as having to integrate
populations from quote-unquote inferior
races
and this opposition implied major checks
on the imperialist urge to expand
but something was happening in the late
1800s that would change the debate about
american expansionism
the industrial revolution produced
explosive economic growth and the bigger
u.s economy required a more centralized
state and bureaucracy to manage the
growing economy
power became concentrated in the federal
government making it easier for
expansionist presidents like william
mckinley to unilaterally push american
influence abroad
the key turning point came in 1898 when
president mckinley dragged the country
into war with spain over cuba
despite some intense domestic opposition
the rising united states easily defeated
the morobun spanish empire acquiring
puerto rico
guam and the philippines in the process
over the next two years the us would
annex the kingdom of hawaii
wake island and american samoa a few
years later the us took control of the
panama
canal zone and sent troops to occupy the
dominican republic
it also purchased the american virgin
islands this period of rapid acquisition
of far-flung territories put the us on
the map as a truly global power
during this time america also began
using its influence to protect its
growing commercial and military
interests abroad
installing pro-american regimes in
places like nicaragua and playing a
major role in international diplomacy
regarding the western presence in china
world war 1 showed just how much
america's influence had grown
not only was american intervention a
decisive factor in the war's end
but president wilson attended the paris
peace conference which ended the war
and attempted to set the terms of the
peace he spearheaded america's most
ambitious foreign policy initiative yet
an international organization called the
league of nations designed to promote
peace and cooperation globally
the league a wholesale effort to remake
global politics
showed just how ambitious american
foreign policy had become
yet isolationism was still a major force
in the united states
[Music]
congress blocked the united states from
joining the league of nations dooming
wilson's project
during the great depression and the rise
of hitler the us was much more focused
on its own region than on european
affairs
ultimately america's ever-growing
entanglements abroad made it impossible
for it to stay out of global affairs
entirely
in east asia the growing japanese empire
posed a direct
threat to american possessions and
troops bringing the united states and
japan into conflict
this culminated in the pearl harbor
attack bringing the united states into
world war ii
world war ii would transform america's
global presence forever
the united states was the only major
power to avoid economic ruin during the
war
and it was the sole country equipped
with atomic weapons as such it was in a
unique position to set the terms of the
peace
and with the aim of preventing another
war in mind it took advantage
the most famous example of this is the
creation of the united nations
the u.n charter set up a system of
international law prohibiting wars of
conquest
like the ones waged by the nazis and the
japanese it also served as a forum in
which the international community could
weigh in on disputes
and help resolve them this way the
americans hoped
great powers could resolve their
differences through compromise and law
rather than war but while the un is the
most famous of the post-war institutions
it isn't the only one 730 delegates from
all 44 allied nations came together in a
small vacation haven in new hampshire
their goal to establish a global
financial system that would prevent
another great depression and world war
the resulting agreement called the
bretton woods agreement ultimately came
the backbone of the global financial
system
resulting in the world bank and the
international monetary fund
by creating these institutions the
united states committed itself to being
deeply involved in the world's problems
[Music]
the issue though is that the world's
second largest power the soviet union
saw things differently world war ii had
made allies out of the democratic west
and communist east in the fight against
hitler but that couldn't last the united
states saw soviet expansion in eastern
europe and elsewhere as a direct threat
to its vision of a free trading
democratic world
to a substantial degree in one farm or
another
socialism has spread the shadow of human
regimentation
over most of the nations of the earth
and
the shadow is encroaching upon our own
liberty
fearful of soviet intentions towards
western europe the u.s and other
european nations created the north
atlantic treaty organization
a military alliance meant to stop russia
from invading other countries in europe
globally the u.s committed to a strategy
called containment so-called because it
was aimed at containing the spread of
communism
everywhere on the globe this new global
struggle meant the us had to exert
influence everywhere
all the time instead of disbanding the
massive military machine created for
world war ii
the wheels mostly kept turning
this had two main results first the us
was pulled into
unlikely alliances with countries like
saudi arabia
israel and south korea seeing each of
them as bulwarks against communist
influence in their region
the us began intervening often secretly
in dozens of countries to contain soviet
influence
sometimes this meant propping up
sympathetic dictators like in iran
other times it meant supplying rebels
with arms and money like in afghanistan
in 1979
and nicaragua in 1985. over the course
of the cold war
the u.s intervened in hundreds of
disputes around the globe ending up with
a complicated set of alliances tensions
and relationships in basically every
corner of the earth
after the berlin wall fell the us could
have withdrawn from the system
severing ties with its allies and
drawing down the size of its military
and while the us did decrease military
spending much of the military
infrastructure
and alliances from the cold war remained
presidents george h.w
bush and bill clinton decided that it
was in both america and the world's
interests for the united states now the
sole superpower on earth
to continue actively managing global
affairs
we should be and we must be peacemakers
nato created solely as a tool for
countering the soviet union
stayed together and even expanded a way
of keeping european nations united in
the absence of the soviet threat
washington's support for countries like
israel and japan stayed intact
ostensibly as a means of preventing war
in their respective regions
the global system of alliances and
institutions created to keep the peace
during the cold war became permanent as
did the american military and political
commitments necessary to keep them
running
the system remains in operation today
and no leading american politicians
since the cold war
seriously called for dismantling it
except
perhaps for donald trump trump has said
contradictory things about these
commitments
but he's consistently argued that
american allies are not paying the u.s
enough for its protection
and question the value of free trade
that calls nato and even the world trade
organization into question
at some point we have to say you know
what we're better off if japan protects
itself against this maniac in north
korea
we're better off frankly if south korea
is going to start to protect it
saudi arabia saudi arabia absolutely
this is a sharp divergence from the
consensus that has dominated u.s foreign
policy since 1945
and something closer to the isolationism
that came before it
so will president trump act on some of
canada trump's ideas
and reverse decades worth of institution
building and alliances
we'll find out soon enough